same way with the conservative grifters
fighting each other every time you go
man this is so awesome Crowders finally
going down and everybody's like oh see
you're some daily wire [__] and I'm like
no no I want them all to destroy each
other
I'm not picking aside here I want it to
be literally a smoky glassed Wasteland
when this is all said and done and all
these people eat each other that's what
I want
[Music]
oh sorry that's my fault
there you go
[Music]
so
the Crowder
crash in Burn Arc we didn't see that
coming
but also did we see
the we're gonna end up feeling bad for
Brian Callan story I I was gonna about
to say that I I can't I am starting to
feel real genuine sympathy for Brian
Cowan yeah
yeah no for real I mean I agree shut up
button and now Crowders involving him in
his gay humiliation rituals
I never thought I'd say this
you're better off with papa papa
let's see what I could do here he was
better off with Baba oh god there it is
there you go boys it's like why would
you post this there it is let's watch it
on our set what do you say
strange animal
s
dude it's so [__] that is [__] art
[__] Crowder slapping [__] Brian
cowling on the ass over top of the ROTC
oh yeah dude
[Music]
this is so sad
even if I knew the context I would say
these people are gay and I don't think
you know what I don't think Alan's gay I
made that joke yesterday I don't think
Helen's gay I think Crowder is gay no
callum's not gay he's just divorced he
needs that money
so
basically
and I and I really I don't know how to
describe it Brian Callan is just a
traveling cuck for these shows now is
that what he is like he just does
whatever they say he'll let him flash a
[__] light on the screen he doesn't
give you know what I mean yeah is is
that is that what's going on with these
people Marsh pointed it out like Crowder
just [__] keeps pushing everything
down in his timeline by retweeting other
people
not only that but now all of his tweets
are literally all the other shows that
he's got on mug club now so he's only
tweeting like a video clip of Nick
depaolo a video clip of Jim Brewer a
video clip you know what I mean like all
these other things because
every time he tweets himself everyone's
like yeah [__] piece of [__] but when
he tweets a clip of Nick de Paulo he
still gets a few you [__] piece of
[__] but a lot of people are responding
with normal like oh yeah that's cool you
know hey Marsh you're you're gonna need
up sorry
look at the light look at the light
Marsh come on man
come on
we're doing a bit here
okay lights off now you could you could
talk again sorry okay
no it's even better because he puts the
light on to shut you up and then he's
like yeah
and it's like that's why you shut me up
like you were on a roll oh my God you're
right like it's a good point he shuts
you up for like garbage it's [__]
good [__] yeah like he was [__]
fired up like look Roy some gun [__]
like Furious about something right and I
don't need light to shut up I'll just be
like okay Royce is about to do a 10
minute like [__] and it said he's
literally like the cartoon [__] uh
yeah you know the steam like the old
school yeah that's like
I'm like okay just he's gonna go off but
like at least you're like raging and
it's a good bit it's not like hey hey
Murph shut up I'm doing my wacky voice I
hate hey I'm doing I'm doing my work I'm
doing my impression so anyway I walked
into a bar Bernie Sanders was there
talking to Joe Biden and it sounded a
little something like this
he's doing [__] 90s coming Crowder
you're a hack and you shock
you're a [__] hack and you suck and
guess what oh I'm sorry hold on let me
pull something up because it's important
uh let me where is it where is it where
is it where is it where is it okay and
don't I don't think we've forgotten
Crowder don't you think we've forgotten
there it is three weeks ago come on come
on where are they
where are they he had a new song
he had a he had a new song
a really funny song Let me see if I can
grab it
oh my God okay while I find the song I
now I have to read you the name of his
parodies because we've done some of
these but I don't think you know all the
names you ready
Dr Trump
okay Best of You A Foo Fighters parody
smells like two spirit a Nirvana parody
God these are so bad She's So High
Spirit that wouldn't make me real bad
Crowder gonna give it to you hi
yeah exactly he's gonna give you a
[__] smack if you don't get his steak
in his wood pallets Wuhan mistake
the hunter Biden song this [__] is
cringy she drives me crazy song parody
We Didn't Start the Fire Billy Joel
parody oh my God he's so [__] happy
he's a hack he's a [__]
one-dimensional hack
do you like Taking Back Sunday
[Music]
I remember this I remember we covered
this one too
and that's just the words the song
remember this yeah yeah it's good
it's a stanzo it's nice
[Music]
it's probably
look I I I
obviously Taking Back Sunday is one of
the cringier guilty pleasures that I
still enjoy
but like
come on man don't [__] this up for me
Steve I got a few things left that I I
got a few things that I could put on
once in a while that make me feel young
and happy again for five minutes before
I realize that I'm way closer to death
than I've ever been okay don't ruin them
for me with your fagotry
you know how I justify uh listening to
Taking Back Sunday still every time I
throw it on I go well I still listen to
the first brand new album so
yeah it's true